oh hi we're down here at the game
developers conference where I have found
myself at a massive giant human hamster
ball called the virtue sphere the virtue
sphere is about 10 feet high it's about
650 pounds of plastic and it'll run you
about thirty thousand dollars it can be
used for video games like the first
person shooter alien shooting running
around game that I just played or it can
actually be used for more serious
training applications so inside the
virtue spear you wear this virtual
reality helmet and uh the image of a
first-person shooter with a bunch of
aliens running around and trying to
shoot at you is on your goggles and I
should run forward in the fall moving
underneath you you run forward and run
up to the aliens and you have the gun
and you can blast them and basically it
attracts your head movements so it knows
where you're looking and that's how you
ain't the virtual reality headset is
pretty massive on my head but it
actually felt pretty good for a short
burst of gaming I definitely almost lost
my balance a couple of times but I think
that's just me i have terrible balance i
think if you get used to running around
in the virtuous fear it would actually
be pretty fun and natural feeling once
you're used to the feeling of the ball
rotating under your feet I kept trying
to lean forward and they had to keep
telling you know just walk normally one
of Sony's big pushes across all of its
technology platforms this year is 3d 3d
movies 3d television and 3d gaming on
PlayStation 3 which they're going to
roll out later in 2010 now these are not
the red and blue glasses of our youth
the nor are they the polarized glasses
that used to watch avatar five times in
a row on opening day these are
mechanized LCD glasses which actually
turn on and off sending different
signals to each eye for games like Super
Stardust HD here in vaca me which as you
can see looks really awesome oxo you
can't see it I'm sorry
wish you were here something else Sonia
showing near the game developers
conference is playstation move motion
controller for ps3 basically it's Sony's
answer to the weed does everything the
Wii Remote does wave it around you can
play tennis you can swing a baseball bat
all that good stuff now there's a camera
on top of the television and that tracks
the movement of this light up ball and
controller and that's how it knows where
it is there's gyroscopes and
accelerometers so it's no words moving
around there's buttons sources trigger
so you can use it as a gun you know the
drill there's also the sub controller
here that it's an optional accessory now
this actually doesn't have motion in it
what it does add a joystick and buttons
so you can place a a first-person
shooter by moving around with the
joystick and aiming and pointing and
firing with the motion controller now
there's one thing that the PlayStation
Move can do that you're not going to be
doing on your wii anytime soon which is
augmented reality since there's a camera
it can actually track the position to
controller and then replace the
controller in the image with whatever
you want I got a couple of swords or a
sword and a baseball bat or a sword and
another controller or a thing or this so
the sony logo ow I've been trying out
playstation move here at GDC and
basically it works like the wii remote
in some cases it works just as well
maybe a little bit better you know
playing table tennis stuff like that but
as far as the first person shooter
controller I kind of found that using
the camera to track the ball it's a
little bit laggy ER than the wii's
solution like it doesn't really moves
where I want it to go it's sort of
trails after me like it's kind of
following along with my movements in
that respect I actually kind of like the
least controller better a lot of the
software they're showing off here at GDC
isn't really up to the standards of what
Nintendo has on the Wii right now like
the table tennis doesn't feel is good
the archery in the bowling all don't
really feel as good so Sony's controller
which it says it's going to cost about a
hundred dollars is actually it's got
more technology in it than the week but
right now the games that they're showing
aren't as good
you